[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه الجديده من
مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
السعوديه والامارات تقود القاطره الخليجيه
نحو صافي صفر انبعاثات فكيف تحددان
اهدافهما الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
تتوقع اعتمادا اوروبيا متزايدا على
الهيدروجين الاخضر من المنطقه العربيه في
السنوات المقبله
[موسيقى]
اعلنت كل دول الخليج عن اهدافها بتحقيق
صافي سفر انبعاثات حيث يتطلب اتفاق باريس
للمناخ من جميع المواقعين عليه تحديد
الاهداف والمعروفه باسم المساهمات المحدده
وطنيا والمحافظه عليها وبما ان قطاع
الطاقه يعد مصدرا اساسيا للانبعاثات تعتمد
دول المنطقه بشكل رئيسي على نشر الطاقه
المتجدده للوفاء بالتزاماتها المناخيه على
الرغم من ان استراتيجيات صافي صفر
انبعاثات تشمل مبادرات اخرى وتعد السعوديه
والامارات المسؤولتان عن معظم انبعاثات
غازات الاحتباس الحراري في منطقه الخليج
بحكم حجم اقتصاداتهما وقد كشفت حكومه
البلدين عن اهدافهما لصافي صفر بعثات ووضع
خارطه الطريق لتحقيق اهدافهما المناخيه
خلال السنتين الماضيتين وكما في عام 20 21
كان حوالي 90% من القدره الانتاجيه للطاقه
المتجدده المركبه في منطقه الخليج تقع في
كل من السعوديه والامارات الجدير بالذكر
ان بعض الدول العالم بما فيها كل دول
الخليج وضعت مساهماتها المحدده وطنيا من
خلال الاشاره الى سيناريو العمل المعتاد
كمؤشر قياس وهو السيناريو الاساسي القائم
على الانبعاثات التي يتوقع حدوثها اذا لم
يتم اتخاذ اي خطوات للتخفيف من تغير
المناخ مقارنه بسنه الاساس كما يؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار ايضا تاثير النمو الاقتصادي على
الانبعاثات وهذا يعني ان الانبعاثات في
بعض البلدان قد تستمر في الزياده على
المدى القصير ولكن بوتيره اقل مقارنه
بالسيناريو الذي لم يتخذ فيه اي اجراءات
ففي عام 20 21 اعلنت السعوديه عن تحديث
مساهمتها المحدده وطنيا حيث تعتزم المملكه
الان خفضه وتجنب وازاله انبعاثات سنويه
بمقدار 278 مليون طن من مكافئ ثاني اكسيد
الكربون بحلول عام 2030 مستخدمه سنه 2019
كسنه اساس ولتحقيق هذا الهدف تسعى المملكه
الى توليد حوالي 50% من طاقتها الكهربائيه
من مصادر متجدده بحلول عام 2030 كما حددت
المملكه هدفها لصافي صفر بعثات بحلول عام
2060 اما الامارات ففي عام 2022
رفعت هدفها لخفض انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس
الحراري الى 31% بحلول عام 2030 مقارنه
بسيناريو العمل كالمعتاد حيث كان التزامها
السابق هو خفض بنسبه 23 ونصف في المئه وفي
اطار مساهماتها المحدده وطنيا الجديده
ستحد الامارات من انبعاثاتها في عام 2030
ب 208 ملايين طن من مكافئ ثاني اكسيد
الكربون مقارنه باكثر من 300 مليون طن
المتوقعه بموجب سيناريو العمل المعتاد
الخاص بها حيث تسعى الامارات الى الوصول
بالطاقه النظيفه كنسبه من اجمالي مزيج
الطاقه الى 30% بحلول عام 2030 والى 50%
بحلول عام 2050 مع التنويه هنا الى ان هذه
النسبه تشمل ايضا الطاقه النوويه
حتى الان دول الخليج اعتمدت على الطاقه
الشمسيه اكثر من اي تقنيه اخرى من تقنيه
الطاقات المتجدده حيث ان 97% من القدره
الانتاجيه المركبه للطاقه المتجدده في دول
الخليج مرتبطه بالطاقه الشمسيه بحسب
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه المتجدده ايرينا
السبب الرئيسي في ذلك هو الظروف الملائمه
لتوليد الطاقه الشمسيه في المنطقه حيث
تتمتع بمستويات عاليه من الاشعاع الشمسي
ومن عدد ساعات ضوء الشمس على مدار السنه
كما ان المنطقه لديها مساحات واسعه من
الاراضي الخاليه المناسبه لتشييد منظومات
الالواح الكهروضوئيه اضافه الى ان منحنيات
الانتاج والطلب متطابقان بشكل جيد حيث
يبلغ التوليد والاستهلاك ذروتهما في
النهار وفي موسم الصيف لكن وعلى الرغم من
ان الطاقه الشمسيه هي التقنيه السائده
لتوليد الطاقه المتجدده في معظم الا ان
بعض البلدان مثل البحرين والكويت
والسعوديه وسلطنه عمان قد ادخلت بنهايه
عام 2021
طاقه الرياح ايضا في مزيج الطاقه المستهدف
حيث يعد مشروع دومه الجندل اول محطه لطاقه
الرياح في السعوديه واكبر محطه لطاقه
الرياح قيد التشغيل في المنطقه حيث تبلغ
قدرتها الانتاجيه 400 ميجا وات تقوم
السعوديه ايضا بتطوير محطات اخرى لطاقه
الرياح في ينبع ب 700 ميجاوات ومشروع وعد
الشمال بخمسمائه ومنطقه الغاط ب 600 ميجا
وات فقد قفزت القدره الانتاجيه لتوليد
الطاقه المتجدده المتصله بالشبكه في
السعوديه الى 700 ميجا وات في عام 2022 من
حوالي 24 ميجا وات فقط في عام 2016
ويجري تطوير قدره انتاج اض افيه في
السعوديه بمقدار
11.4 جيجا وات ومع اقتراب عام 2020
ودخول مشاريع في دول اخرى في المنطقه قيد
التشغيل من المرتقب تسارع وتيره انتشار
الطاقات المتجدده في الخليج بشكل اكبر
لتعزيز الجهود المناخيه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
قطاع متنام ينشا في السعوديه للصناعات
المرتبطه بكفاءه الطاقه والطاقه المتجدده
مع اتساع نطاق توطين المحتوى المحلي بحيث
يتزايد التصنيع المحلي للعدادات الذكيه
والواح الطاقه الشمسيه وغيرها من المعدات
المرتبطه بالطاقات المتجدده
التقينا عبد الرؤوف المدير التنفيذي
في شركه الفنار وسالناه عن التطور الذي
طرا على صناعه المنتجات الكهربائيه في
المملكه في السنوات الاخيره
المفاتيح التي تستخدم في البيوت احنا
بنستخدم معها
السمارت
اليوشن تلعب دور كبير من الهوم
هوم
وسمارت هوم اكلمك على
الاتمته المستخدمه في البيوت ونطلع على
الاتمته المستخدمه في شبكات الضغط المتوسط
وبعدين نطلع الاتمته المستخدمه في شبكات
الجهد العالي هذا كله انا كلمتك عن
التصنيع في باور او الطاقه التقليديه طبعا
الطاقه التقليديه احنا مصنعين لمحطات
الضغط المتوسط والضغط العالي وكمان الضغط
المنخفض ومصنعين للمحولات مصنعين للكابلات
ومصنعين
المجورتي المواد المستخدمه في التوزيع
والنقل الكهربائي وكمان فيها مو بس
تصنيعنا في
تستخدم في نقل المعرفه من الاستحوادادات
اللي احنا بنعملها للشركات اللي بتساعدنا
في نقل المعرفه الى الداخل ونقدر نصنع
ونطور من البرودكت والمنتجات اللي موجوده
بالحديث عن الاستحواذات ما هي القطاعات
المستهدفه طبعا الاستحواذات بدات في
البدايه في الطاقه
التقليديه اللي انا ذكرت لك اياها اللي هي
المحطات والمحولات والكيبلات بعدين نحن
نقلنا للمستقبل الشركه اللي هو او
المستقبل
التوزيع الكهربائي اللي هي الاتمته او
الشبكات الذكيه فاستحودنا على شركه في
اسبانيا تنتج
المرحلات وكذلك وحدات التحكم عن بعد
هذول المنتجين مستخدموا بقوه في
اتمته الشبكات وتجعلها شبكات ذكيه اليوم
بعد هذا كله
عندنا كمان المستقبل رؤيه المملكه
انه نوصل ل 50% من الانتاج الكهربائي يكون
عن طريق الطاقه المتجدده اليوم الفنارس
تحودت على الشركه تنتج الوينتر باين
المستخدم في
الطاقه المتجدده عن طريق الرياح كمان
استحودنا على شركه
بتنتج
الانفرترز او العاكس وهو اعقد جزء في
منظومه نقل الكهرباء من بعد ما تنتجوا من
عن طريق الطاقه المتجدده وربطه بالشبكه
الموجوده في في التوزيع الكهربائي
هذا الانفرتر بكل فخر برضه صنع في
السعوديه اليوم الطاقه
الانتاجيه لهذا
النص جيجا في السنه بحول الله عندنا
خطط توسعويه نوصل الى الى
وان جيجا خلال سنتين وان شاء الله باذن
الكريم كمان حنطلع اكثر من كذا على حسب
الطلب الموجود في السوق ومدى استمراريه
الطلب المشاريع
في السياق نفسه تحدثنا مع خالد البعيز
رئيس مجموعه خالد فهد البعيز القابضه عن
تسارع توطين تقنيات كفاءه الطاقه والطاقات
المتجدده في السعوديه
كل المنتجات اللي وطنت وطنت مع شركاء
من من اوروبا او من الصين او من الهند ومن
اي مكان
ونسبه المحتوى المحلي ترتقي
كل سنه ترتقيل تباعا لمتطلبات هيئه هيئه
المحتوى المحلي وطنا في في منف اكثر من من
مئه منتج
الان احنا نورد لشركه الكهرباء السعوديه
للشركات اكثر من 150 منتج ابروفت مختبر
عالميا في في
مختبرات عالميه
يعني كان كان في مشروع ضخم
في سنه 2020
للعدادات الكهربائيه سمارت ميتر اعدادات
الذكيه
وعمل اكبر مشروع يمكن عمل
يعني على علمي في العالم انه توطن اكثر من
عشره مليون عداد في سنه والسنه هذه كانت
صعبه كانت كوفيد وكانت ومع ذلك بفضل الله
نجح نجحت مجموعه
المنفذين هذا المشروع في انجازها في الوقت
المناسب كنا احد الموردين في هذا المشروع
ركبنا في الشبكه اكثر من مليون وسبعمئه
الف عداد
الان
انتقلوا ايضا الى احلال
جميع اجهزه
التوزيع بان تكون سمارت
والهدف بانه يتكون شبكه ذكيه كامله في
المملكه على على مستوى المملكه بدا
المشروع فعل فعلا ايضا احنا من اللاعبين
الجيدين في هذا في توطين منتجات خاصه بهذا
المشروع
باستثمارات كبيره جدا يعني
بدانا في حدود اكثر من 350 مليون ريال
سعودي
لما يخص
شبكه
التوزيع والنقل الذكي
كم تسهم في عمليه كفاءه الطاقه
سمارت اذا اكتملت منظومه السمارت جريد لا
شك بانها ستسهم كثيرا في في منظومه كفاءه
الطاقه وترشيد الطاقه
بلا شك ايضا بتعطي اذا تكونت
اذا تكونت المنظومه كامله بالطريقه الذكيه
تعطي ايضا
فرصه
للمزود الطاقه
بطريقه المنظر وتغيير نقل الحمل من مكان
الى اخر من الكنترول روم ما في احد يروح
له لمواقع معينه ويفصل او يحفر او كذا
[موسيقى]
نتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع فاصل قصير نتابع
بعده في مستقبل الطاقه
مهتمه بمشاريع الطاقه المتجدده في
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه اربعه
تغييرات كبيره طرات على المشهد مشهد
الطاقه الاوروبيه نتيجه لدروس الحرب في
اوكرانيا بعد مرور سنه على اندلاعها اولا
تسارع لمشاريع طاقه الرياح البحريه ثانيا
اقتصاد الهيدروجين الاخضر بدا ياخذ حيزه
الحقيقي مع تزايد الاتفاقيات لانتاجه في
عدد من الدول العربيه
وثالثا اعتماد متزايد على الغاز المسالم
ورابعا الاهتمام بمشاريع الربط الكهربائي
هذه الاتجاهات لخصها كريم امين عضو مجلس
الاداره التنفيذي في الطاقه في مقابله
خاصه لمستقبل الطاقه لكن قبل ذلك تحدث لنا
عن العقود التي وقعتها شركته مؤخرا في
العراق واهتمامها بمشاريع الطاقه المتجدده
في السعوديه لنتابع
العراق طبعا لها خريطه طريق سيما اسكت
شغاله عليها تقريبا بقى لها سنه ونص او
سنتين
تستهدف ان تزود الطاقه المنتجه من الطاقه
الكهربائيه تقريبا حوالي 15 جيجا 15 جيجا
ده يكون 50% من كميه الطاقه الكهربائيه
اللي موجوده حاليا في العراق وكمان تقويه
وتدعيم شبكه نقل الكهرباء بحيث ان
الكهرباء اللي تنتج تقدر يتم نقلها بطريقه
فعاله وبدون خسائر كثير في نفس الوقت كمان
كان في بعض المشاريع الخاصه بالغاز
المصاحب احنا طبعا عارفين ان العراق فيها
غاز مصاحب بيتم حرقه في الهوا عندنا مشروع
او اثنين بيستهدفوا ان احنا نقدر نلتقي
الغاز المصاحب ونعالجه ثم يتم استخدامه ان
انت تنتج بيه الطاقه الكهربائيه نظيفه فدي
خليط الطريق في عجاله نتوقع ان هي هتكون
يعني استثمارات من الحكومه العراقيه يعني
تتخطى
450 مليون
ماذا عن المنطقه العربيه ومشاريع الطاقه
النظيفه التي تنظرون اليها يعني منطقه
عربيه برضو
تشهد
بالذات في منطقه الخليج العربي يعني لو
خدنا السعوديه على سبيل المثال السعوديه
عندها رؤيه 20 رؤيه 2050 تستهدف ان الحوض
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على خارطه
العالم فيما يخص انتاج الطاقه النظيفه
والمتجدده سواء من الرياح او من الطاقه
الشمسيه وكمان انتاج الهيدروجين الاخضر
وفي مشاريع حاليا بيتم مفاوضتها وترسيتها
في السعوديه واحنا داخلين في اكثر من
مشروع فيهم يعني في اللمسات الاخيره منهم
لكن متوقع كمان في الفتره القادمه ان يكون
في تقريبا في حدود 7 جيجا من المشاريع
الجديده اللي هيتم طرحها تباعا
سواء في مجال الهواء
او حتى في مجال الغاز
بالحديث عن الغاز دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وبعد الازمه الاوكرانيه اتجهت بعيدا عن
الغاز الروسي نحو الطاقات المتجدده
والنظيفه هل تعتقد انها ستنجح في ذلك طبعا
الازمه اللي حصلت نتيجه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا يعني كانت بمثابه ناقوس خطر
بيوضح جامد جدا للعالم وخاصه للقاره
الاوروبيه بدا اهميه توفر الطاقه في نفس
الوقت الاستدامه
والمعقوليه الاسعار ثلاث نقاط دي بتكمل
بعضها ولازم تكون موجوده في اي معادله دول
بتنظر لها لما تكون بتخطط لمستقبل الطاقه
الخاص بها شفنا في الفتره الاخيره
يعني بسرعه غير مسبوقه بالذات مثلا في
دوله زي المانيا انه ابتدى يبقى في
خطوط للغاز المسالي المانيا كدوله ما كانش
فيها اطلاقا اي غاز مثال في اقل من سنه
المانيا تحط اتنين تيرمينال للغاز المساعد
وتمت التوقيع على اتفاقيات خاصه بتوريد
الهيدروجين
فهذه كلها مشاريع تمت بصوره عاديه اتصور
انك هتشوف الفتره القادمه اوروبا بتتجه
اتجاه سريع جدا واحد للطاقه النظيفه
المتجدده بالذات طاقه الرياح خاصه فيما
يخص ما يطلق عليه اوف شور او في البحر
هتشوف
اقتصاد الهيدروجين في اوروبا
بيقف على رجليه بصوره واضحه جدا
والهيدروجين دايما محتاج انك انت تنتجه من
طاقه متجدده فهنلاقي المنطقه العربيه
عندنا بتلعب دور مهم جدا في هذا الموضوع
خاصه انتاج الهيدروجين الاخضر من الطاقه
الشمسيه او من طاقه الرياح وهتلاقي كمان
مشاريع قويه جدا فيما يخص بالربط الكهربي
ما بين الدول
ده موضوع هنشوفه بيكسره في الفتره الجايه
ولكن متى سيصبح الهيدروجين مجدي تجاريا
بالتاكيد يحتاج الى وقت واستثمارات
هو حاليا غير مجدي لكن خلينا نتفق انه في
تمن وفي ساعه لتوفر الطاقه وفي تمن وفيه
ساعه لتوفر هذه الطاقه بصوره
صديقه للبيئه
لما نشوف الموضوع ده تم يعني بناء الدول
تبني عليه نوع من انواع التحفيز ويكون في
قوانين
تغرم
البعثات الكربونيه واحنا اتكلمنا يمكن
يعني قبل كده على موضوع الشهادات الخضراء
الكربون لما نلاقي ان الشهادات الخضراء
للكربون دي لها سعر والسعر ده سعر حقيقي
بيعكس تاثير الكربون الضار جدا على البيئه
هتبتدي تشوف ان الكربون ان الهيدروجين
ابتدى يبقى يعني
صادي وله سوق لكن مما لا شك فيه ان اوروبا
خدت خلاص القرار لان البنيه التحتيه
البنيه يمكن شفنا من حوالي اسبوع اتفاقيه
كبيره جدا تمت ما بين المانيا والنرويج
بناء خط انابيب ما بين النرويج والمانيا
بيجيب من النرويج الهيدروجين لالمانيا وفي
خط صاحب له بينقل الكربون من المانيا الى
النرويج حتى يتم ضخه في تحت البحر انه
بيساعد في برضو في في استخراج الغاز فده
يعني واضح جدا انه المشاريع دي هتبقى
فاتحه ان المشاريع الهيدروجين تبقى قائمه
بصوره اقتصاديه هناك ايضا تحديات اخرى
تواجه هذا النمو مثل التضخم وارتفاع اسعار
المعادن كيف تنظرون الى عمليه تحول الطاقه
يعني خلينا نقول التحدي ده انا شايفه اكبر
تحدي ويمكن لا يسلط عليه الضوء كتير في
الاعلام لكن
قدره المواد الاوليه اللي احنا بنحتاجها
علشان
الصناعه
للتربينات الهواء او الصناعه الالواح
الشمس او حتى للاجهزه والمعدات اللي بتنتج
الهيدروجين يعني لها حدود
واحتياجنا احنا للتحول للطاقه اكبر بكتير
في الفتره الزمنيه من ما هو متاح اتصور ان
انت هتشوف طبعا في الفتره الجايه
استثمارات برده
قائمه بقوه انك تقدر انك تعظم وتقدر يعني
يبقى عندك قدره اكبر على التعدين وعلى انك
توجد هذه المعادن لكن مما لا شك فيه ان هو
عامل مؤثر وهنشوفه بياثر على قدرتنا ان
احنا ننتقل في الوقت والسرعه اللي احنا
محتاجينها
النمو العالمي خلال الفتره المقبله يتطلب
مزيدا من الطاقه هل ستبقى الطاقه
التقليديه مرتكزا لتلبيه هذا الطلب
محتاج اقصى قدر من الطاقه باقل قدر من
الانبعاثات ده يعني ان ما فيش تكنولوجيا
بعينها او طريقه بعينها لانتاج الطاقه
نقدر ان احنا نعتمد عليها فقط ونترك الاخر
لازم ان احنا نتعامل مع كل المتاح قدامنا
لان زي ما حضرتك تفضلت احنا محتاجين نتيجه
الزياده السكانيه ونتيجه
الاحتياج ان احنا برضه للصناعه
وللتقدم الانساني بصفه عامه دائما محتاجين
طاقه اكثر يعني على سنه 2030 احنا هنحتاج
50% من الطاقه اللي عندنا دلوقتي زياده
وبالتالي احنا لازم نشتغل على كل المحاور
مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه
المستقبل الطاقه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]